for the third year in a row ladies and
gentlemen we are taking our show down to
San Diego for Comic Con airing here's
the deal we'll be airing a week of shows
live from the Spreckels Theatre in San
Diego we got lots of exciting stuff
planned incredible guests lined up
it's all happening Wednesday July 19th
through Sunday July 23rd not quite our
normal schedule but that's how we're
doing it tickets to our Comic Con show
will be available starting this Friday
for more information visit team koco.com
slash comic-con
really good time you know toting that is
great news but I just wish there is more
there is more Andy that's crazy
yeah that's like that was written on the
card or something the company the
company that makes pop vinyl figures
Funko has once again created four new
limited edition conan pop figures for
the yes now for the third year in a row
we'll be giving out these figures to our
audiences at comic-con and these things
you get on eBay they blow up check them
out this is this year's selection right
here here they are look at this guy
there's Conan as spider-man that's
Spidey Conan
there's Jedi Conan this year
there's the flash Conan
and then look at that guy wait walker
Conan
my favorite right there white Walker
Kona is just real Conan without a shirt
on see hey Conan
I got a one-of-a-kind toy made for me
too
lebombo that's just a turn up with a
fake mustache and a hat I'm mentally ill
yeah okay
[Applause]
you